[Music]
Brian's with us in Bakersfield
California hey Brian how are you better
than I've been there Dave how are you
better than I deserve how can I help
okay Dave so before I found you at the
beginning of this year I impulse and
purchase a ridiculous car and as soon as
I found you I was like crap what'd you
buy we bought a 2017 Mazda 6 with all
the bells and whistles
so wheat yeah well not so sweet because
my pocket hurts yeah well I guess but I
mean the car is great yeah yeah okay oh
yeah
so what on this silly thing we old
35,000 mm-hmm okay what's your husband
Hanham this year we'll be making 62 65
maybe touching 70 depending on my
overtime oh yeah I just don't know so
then next year I'll be getting a good a
15% raise plus another 5% raise down the
road yeah so here's my I'm calling to
see if you what if you're okay with this
memo I finally agreed to let it go good
and sell it it's worth 21,000 no god
yeah so you're uh you're all something
upside down into it or died that bad
yeah I died that bad it only took like
three months good lord
so 21 goes on trade-in yes
oh well 23 on private sale something
that's not enough to spray it on private
sale so you're saying this car went from
35,000 to 23,000 in one year actually
technically it was 40,000 to 35,000 I
also cancelled the warranty on it
because I we had an extended warranty
yeah and then we found out that it's
funny how when you pay off the vehicle
or you reach certain miles all of a
sudden it starts to fail on you and the
warranties cancelled because you or did
it the cars won over old II and I almost
a year old yeah all right oh yeah when
you get rid of this thing for so many
reasons so so what's your plan
the plan is me and my wife you've been
looking around and we saw some four
thousand five thousand dollar cars
I could have save up that money and I
party have it by next and coming refund
but what I was thinking is because our
monthly payment at the throughout the
whole month it's like eight hundred
dollars so because I also have a
pseudonym and the student loan payments
like 168 but almost done with that we
have like six thousand dollars left over
so what what if I just go ahead and sell
this car borrow the difference and then
go to the guy on the car that's selling
for like four or five thousand dollars
and just make payments off of it for
like a hundred bucks and the monthly
payment will go down to four hundred
dollars making the mess yeah I may be
okay with that yeah sure but I I'm not
sure I understood how you're financing
your second car the money buddy telling
us the five thousand dollar car that
you're buying
how are you financing it I'll just go on
ahead just like you know just like
you're gonna go buy a car for a little
down payment on it okay and over the you
know I mean yeah that's fine if you can
just get a regular car loan on it that's
fine
let's do that because we're still
reducing your debt by half right and by
doing this and then you can concentrate
on getting that car paid off and then
getting the hole that you dug with this
other car which is absolutely horrendous
it's a great car I'm surprised that
thing has dropped that far in value make
real sure you got your numbers right on
that because I mean I
the cars are horrible as far as going
down in value I get it I'm a car guy but
they and they go down in value rapidly
but that one is like a black hole for
money under so anything like it that's
incredible what a horrible horrible car
on holding its value so check that and
make sure your number your numbers are a
little high in terms of lost money I
think you maybe you haven't lost as much
I'm hoping you have a lot of so much as
you think you've lost so let's dig into
that a little bit further and you do not
want to sell it to a dealer at wholesale
you want to sell it private sale it
should be in this situation about a five
thousand are different
in other words you should be able to get
five thousand or more out of a cell in a
private cell than you would from a
dealer on something that expensive so
really check those numbers I'm not sure
you've got correct stuff there but wow
what a dadgum kicking the teeth
man you got hammered amazing good luck
with it but yes I would get out of it
for sure it's too much car it's a mess
that's going down in value it's breaking
I mean there's nothing good in this
story
thanks for the call